this is helping you generate income this
is i mean 400 000 subs you got to very
quickly 50 million pot
you can do sponsorships you can do a lot
of different things that's going on with
you got people that are watching so your
mind is not consumed with you know hey i
need money what do i need to do to go
make money so is this is this almost
eliminating the thoughts of
i got to figure out a way to make money
and survive do you think that would have
prevented a lot of guys to get into life
with the technology we have today both
from the camera standpoint as well as
way to make money
i don't i don't know i really don't know
but you know my mindset was being a
gangster and i was a gangster the whole
time
i don't think
i would have turned to this now i might
have
had somebody else use other people and
took a piece of some business that they
were doing in this field that might
interest me hollywood might of interest
me in the background
i'm a camera guy i'm in the back i'm i
don't want to be in the front
now it's different
i am i am in the front everything's
about my voice i can't even duck i can't
even go away from the weekend but
i don't know
there's two sides of this sword
you can make money with it and people
should use it
and use it properly
and make money but the other side is
that i think the whole country now
is in a weird place
there's people who are doing some of
these platforms who are talking about
being in the mafia they're full of [ __ ]
they're not even they wouldn't have
nothing
and everybody seems a lot of them seem
to be lying so you got to disciple which
one is good which one is bad which one
is so there's a confusion about all of
this so it has two edges to this sword
i don't know
and there's a lot of things that are
going on with kids today
that i i mean i don't understand
the whole country is just out of whack
if you would have told me about
this country at this point
if four years ago
three years ago
i would tell you crazy that would never
happen in the united states in what way
which part not every part the
coronavirus the whole thing
i mean the masks no masks i don't even
know what to believe anymore you used to
be you listen to the news
it was gospel oh my god this is what
they're saying on the news cronkite news
cronkite all you know when you went back
the cnn the guy who originally formed
cnn said turner people like that now
they disappeared i don't know what's
running it anymore you don't you can't
believe anything anymore because one day
they're telling you one thing
wear masks don't wear a mess wear two
masks take a shot take another shot
take a booster take another booster
come on bro what what's going on here
two completely different realities about
which channel you watch yeah yeah yeah
and it's do you hear it in all kinds of
[ __ ] you don't know what to believe
this guy fouchy
i mean i don't know if he needs a medal
the sexiest man alive guys yeah yeah
sexy is a man alive well he bullshitted
the whole world
he's part of this whole virus like you
don't know if he's a hero or a [ __ ]
he's a
he's no [ __ ] hero this guy
he's no hero he's paid for my i
understand the highest paid
guy in the federal government
he's supposed to be a doctor he's
supposed to care about us
he's funding this thing in china
with money
like we're paying for that
we're paying
for
to get a bat
who is disgusting and
has all kinds of viruses
and we're getting those viruses and
trying to transform them into
worse viruses the worst virus and making
it that man could catch it
for what reason are we doing it
excuse is so if man catches this
we could uh cure it that's [ __ ]
because
from the bat you can't even get it
first of all bats don't even live near
us and you can't get it so you're
creating something
to see what you can cure
bro millions of people have died from
this
and the word hero bro this is the
furthest thing from a hero
i can't explain what i would like to do
to him
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]